huh on the streets of Bangkok small
protests like this have become
increasingly regular in the weeks
following the country's general election
I don't think the military is going to
let go of power because they know that
move forward will change everything they
know that if move forward leads the
government those old generals will
become irrelevant
the progressive move forward party won
the most votes in the May ballot on an
anti-establishment platform that has put
them at odds with the forces who have
long controlled Thailand through
military-backed rule the issue for the
these agencies and the established
centers of power is the move forward
agenda and move for its agenda
revolves around drastic
and needed reforms of how Italian Works
beginning with the reform of the
military and the monarchy
this week the election body certified
the results of the vote after weeks of
political uncertainty the commission
endorsed the winners of all 500 seats of
the lower house but challenges still
remain for the move forward party and
its Leader Peter Lim jarongrat it's
unclear whether he will be able to
become Prime Minister to do so he will
need support from rival parties or some
of Thailand's 250 Senators the senators
were appointed by the military regime
after the cool midriku in May 2014 so
the Senators represent the
military-backed interests
the young party leader also faces an
election inquiry into shares in a media
company if found guilty he could be
disqualified from politics and even face
prison time
still Peter is undeterred and often out
in public thronged by supporters
earlier this month when he joined a
parade in support of lgbtq Rights he
promised to pass a law allowing same-sex
marriage if he becomes leader and he is
pledged to be a prime minister for
everyone even those who don't support
him but it's still unclear if he will
get the chance to take on that role
Jessica Washington Al Jazeera